السلام عليكم ورحمه الله معكم محمد زيما
الزليني نتابع معا ابرز اخبار الاسبوع
الماضي بايجاز وضمن ابرز الاحداث جوله
اعاده مرتقبه للانتخابات التركيه اجتماع
حكومه نتنياهو تحت حائط البراق فينيسيوس
يواجه العنصريه بالاضافه الى اخبار اخرى
نتابعها معا
نبدا نشرتنا من تركيا التي تتاهب للمره
الاولى في تاريخها لاجراء جوله ثانيه من
الانتخابات الرئاسيه بعد منافسه كبيره في
الجوله الاولى لم يستطع احد المرشحين فصل
المعركه الانتخابيه فيها لنسال الزميل عمر
الحاج الموجود في تركيا لتغطيه الحدث من
هناك
مرحبا عمر
كيف يبدو عندك المشهد
محمد الترقبو لجوله الحسم في هذه
الانتخابات هو المشهد المسيطر هنا في
تركيا وذلك وسط تجاذبات بشان الصوت القومي
في هذه الجوده الفاصله بعد دعم طبعا مرشح
تحالف الاجداد سنان الرئيس بينما وقف زعيم
حزب الظفر التركي والمعادي للاجئين اريد
اصدار الى جانبي مرشح المعارضه كمان
الجهد المنتظره غدا محمد هي الفيصل لذلك
يتوقع ان تكون نسبه التصويت فيها مرتفعه
وهذا ما نشهده الان في اعداد المصوطين في
الخارج لان هذه النسبه ارتفعت بشكل ملحوظ
مقارنه مع الجوله الماضيه يعطيك العافيه
يا عمر الان الى الشان الفلسطيني اذ اجتمع
رئيس الوزراء الاسرائيلي نتنياهو باعضاء
حكومته في نفق تحت حائط البراق الملاصق
للمسجد الاقصى المبارك وذلك لاول مره منذ
عام 2017 واشدد على ضروره استمرار حكوم
بتركيبتها الحاليه من اجل ما سماه وحده
القدس وهو ما اثار ادانات فلسطينيه ودوليه
واسعه لاسيما ان هذا الاجتماع تزامن مع
اقتحام وزير الامن القومي الاسرائيلي
يتامار بن جفير بحات المسجد الاقصى
الحادثه اثارت غضبا واسعا على منصات
التواصل لنقرا لكم بعضا من تغريداتكم
بسمله الرحمن المرعش لتقول لنتجاهل كل ما
صدر من بيانات عربيه واسلاميه تعبر عن
زعلها من اقتحام بن جفير وتغافلت عما هو
اخطر من الزياره رساله نتنياهو من تحت
النفق ومخططه التهويدي السائر بسرعه
قياسيه بدعم مالي خاص منه اما حول النسر
فيقول خبر مؤسف هذا تصعيد خطير يقول ايضا
هذا ما يضعنا نحن الدول العربيه
والاسلاميه في مازق حقيقي
يفرض علينا ان يكون لنا رد فعل على ذلك في
ظل تواصل الهجمات الروسيه على مختلف
المناطق في اوكرانيا كيف تؤكد ان هجومها
المضاد ضد روسيا بدا منذ عده ايام وهو
مستمر موسكو تقر باستهداف القوات
الاوكرانيه مقاطعه
وتقول انها احبطت محاوله دبرتها المخابرات
الاوكرانيه لتخريب محطتين نوويتين روسيتين
كما تعلن عن تعرض احدث البحر الاسود الى
هجوم بزوارق اوكرانيه مسيره وتؤكد نشر
اسلحه نوويه تكتيكيه في بيلاروسيا حليفتها
المجاوره اذا اردتم معرفه المزيد عن هذا
الموضوع يمكنكم مشاهده التقرير المرفق
اسفل في التعليقات الى امريكا وازمه سقف
الدين اذ طلب البيت الابيض والكونغرس برفع
حد الدين دون شروط وذلك ضمن سلسله من
المحادثات بين الرئيس الامريكي جو بايدن
ورئيس المجلس
وبالجمهوريون اصحاب الاغلبيه في المجلس
يقولون انهم لن يدعموا زياده سقف الديون
هذه المره بدون تخفيض الانفاق الحكومي
ولكن مات بعاد تخلف امريكا عن سداد ديونها
في الموعد هذا سؤال اطرحه للزميل يوسف
خطاب مذيع نشره الاقتصاديه يا مرحبا يوسف
وزيره الخزانه الامريكيه تحذر من هذا
التخلف في سداد الدين العام لماذا اولا
لان مكانه الولايات المتحده كاكبر اقتصاد
في العالم مهدده لانها مهدده بالركود
بالاضافه الى ستحدث هناك في الاسواق
الماليه العالميه ايضا وكالات التصنيف
الائتمانيه وضعت الولايات المتحده على
قوائم ما يسمى بقوائم
بانها ان حدث هذا التخلف قبل الخامس من
يونيو هذا يعني انه سيتم اعاده تصنيف
الولايات المتحده سلبا هذا طبعا عنصر خطير
بالاضافه هذا السيناريو محمد تكرر 80 مره
قبل ذلك هذه المره هي الحاديه والثمانين
لكن ليس من المرجح ان يحدث تخلف عن السداد
لكن المساله مساله مساومات ما بين
الجمهوريين والديمقراطيين والرئيس سيكون
له قول كبير وقول فصل في هذا الملف شكرا
جزيلا لك يوسف خطاب الان مشاهدينا الى
الخبر الاخير في انجازنا وهو متعلق بازمه
اللاعب فينيسيوس جونيور مهاجم ريال مدريد
التي تحولت فعليا الى ازمه عالميه اذا
تعرض لاهانات عنصريه من الجماهير في ملعب
هزيمه فريقه امام فالنسيا بالدوري
الاسباني النادي الملكي لجا الى النيابه
العامه للتحقيق فيما سماها جريمه كراهيه
والاتحاد الاسباني لكره القدم الغ ى قرار
طرد النجم البرازيلي وفرض عقوبه ماليه على
فالنسيا قدرها 45 الف يورو كما اغلقت
مدرجات الملعب بشكل جزئي لخمس مباريات
لنذهب الان الى زميل العنبر نامق ليحدثنا
اكثر عن هذه الواقعه مرحبا عمار هلا حتى
مع الزميل عمر تحضيران لمواد الاخباريه
رياضيه المقبل اسف على المقاطعه لماذا
تستمر مشاكل العنصريه في الملاعب
الاسبانيه
هي اذا كانت على الاستمراريه فما عندنا
مشكله انه هناك عقوبات ممكن انه تنهي هذه
الاستمراريه المشكله الحقيقيه في الملاعب
الاوروبيه محمد انه هذه الظاهره اصبحت
يعني اصبحت مصاحبه لدوريات عملاقه لها
سمعه مثل الدوري الاسباني وانت اشرت قبل
قليل حادثه فينيسيوس دوري بحجم الدوري
الاسباني يعاني من هذه الظاهره وبدون ردع
حقيقي يعني الرابطه هناك خلاف الان بين
الرابطه وبين الاتحاد الاسباني لكره القدم
انه من له الصلاحيه بايقاف المباراه ووضع
عقوبات على هذا الامر كي يتم وضع حد لهذه
الظاهره لا تليق بالدوريات الكبرى شكرا
عمار نختم إجازتنا الاسبوعيه كما الاسبوع
الماضي معك كنت في الخير علينا
يعطيكم العافيه على مشاهدته الاسبوع نلتقي
بحول الله اخر الاسبوع المقبل
شكرا السلام عليكم
[موسيقى]